forms are rituals that's how you use
them to tell tell you what you're doing
so let's say on at this point in time I
think oh and my arm comes in like this
well my arm came in like this because my
foot is there except over here this
pressure would've been there if I have
the other one right my mom is getting
pulled that way
it's because my foot step down so keep
the form and use his pressure so that he
doesn't push on door :
yes difference as opposed to I I was
strong
at the same time James might it's not
that I'm soft
so James comes and pushes on the on the
integrity of it I'm not going anywhere
do you get that so it's not that there's
an integrity to it but I'm not it's just
there whoa okay let's go this is just
basic Chinese philosophy when you've
seen the world a little differently okay
I I create my intentions because I add
to them but I'm not going to be just
fluffball
there's a lot of integrity of what I'm
doing so let's go back to this drill so
one hand inside one hand outside okay
and he's going to push he could do
whatever you could move your hand so he
could do like let's do let's do like
strikes okay then he goes to the strikes
and I'm going to yield these thing
there's a yielding but after there's a
center connection and now we're on a
project so I'm gonna practice the
yielding the yielding of this is just
like this distance to heal did you see
that but neither being too far out or
too far in there's a center connection
and then maintaining the
in my floor and because their centre
connection I take that integrity of my
for my posture and I penetrate him to
his center there's a displacement that
happens that's a projection you got it
okay so I don't want you guys to get
trigger so I don't want you to go fast
at this point I want you to feel it feel
it
boom if you lose your balance so great
Paul don't get stuck on what he's doing
don't get hurt okay
I don't go flying through the walls or
anything and again I don't want this to
be so intellectual or you're like wait
wait just make contact you push it right
when I go I'm not going to I don't want
to use the leverage of this levers to
get that so me where you are trying to
find this Center and you attack the
center so I don't want to shove my arm
okay let's so kind of understand there's
many many ways of creating a topsy-turvy
effect in this one but we were looking
for a particular one maybe not even a
topsy-turvy effect so let's say there's
many many ways of generating and pass
the force through his body
we're looking for a particular law that
particular one has added benefits that
other ones don't
so when he goes right he's going like
this do you see this Here I am I'm going
to use the leverage of his shoulder you
see that and I'm going to take his Lima
gravity outside of his base of support
to create a fall but I would not say
that's a projection right so I could do
the same exact thing
do you see but watch his bottom foot now
the base stop move let's watch the first
one again watch this bottom foot that
becomes an axis of rotation for the lion
gravity to try
outside an amazing support yeah so
that's working through a different
mechanics that mechanics is I would say
it's a secondary one to Aikido
so I'm not even when I go like this with
my body I can make it where keep the
foot there axial rotation ladder
grabbing the outside or I could
have my body does it okay so we're
working on the projections
[Music]
not this stuff so whenever you touch
because you should have already had
seven connection you could make full
contact on make the projection on
contact but we wanted to practice the
yield you see but I always do so because
I can do it whatever I touch every
virgin the hard drive the outside the
basic support you could turn and you
should okay again the two mechanics
rejection
[Music]
[Applause]
you can because you maintain
center-to-center connection if you just
move your center it will displace his
center so I don't need to have this
perfect leverage points for these
perfect contact points even when my arm
is here it's not just there it's on the
center so this is my arm just there at
business center okay same thing it's not
just here it's pushing into the center
so this is how you can turn and stuff
okay so this might free you up more
please stop doing that secondly
mechanics you see even as you do the
section mechanics you should still have
this run turn into the tech so when you
guys do like you try to get off the line
the top this part you actually lose arm
and you're just on the arm it has to
stay that that mean they're pushing
you're pulling so that what I do
so start you see they keep the Scoobies
from last night
so if you pay attention like I'm not
waiting here hold energy
[Music]
that would have been a yield so you
yield yield on one hand so you can press
on the other start picking it up you're
losing you losing connection every time
on that one
[Music]
try for the first mechanic not that
that's just the way history words I
guarantee you there were centuries of an
oral tradition okay and around five BCE
we know that what the Chinese were doing
was doing they call them dances or
rituals and the idea was that you would
do a routine wearing you
at every level of your being experience
this the cosmos which was this yunyoung
transference okay so that there's that's
an element in this what had will begin
and it has to be so the other hand can
be young he can be young then I could be
here then I would be young and he will
be in there then the young will be on
the upper part of our bodies and yet on
the lower then it'll change and we're
constantly experiencing this
cosmological understanding of and okay
so when I watching you guys as you will
what you want to be like you remember
how I said I have connectional time I do
but you have young you have young you're
plus so the guy the guy leans on me all
right but looking what make that
conflict that I did not want to move so
he comes to lean on me you get it
so you your life is my turn to be young
like no it's not your Chargers
time to pee it okay wait you're doing
that for the very beginning when he
pushes you see you lick my weight
go back look at my hand did I need to do
that
nope nope you see it's not running away
it's setting up now uh he's to farted
and I could displace your displacement
power is related to your gone to your
yen yielding if you keep them out there
you won't have much displacement because
you gonna have to take a big step
[Music]
this is yen right this one is young she
won't let you come in on me you see that
so but if it starts to be overpowering
look then this hand went yet right this
hands young I'll show you the gym
buddies doing already standing up
from the first mechanics there it is
right there was happy right
it was having to get some more yen in
there and more keep musubi at the start
don't wait so long you already started
moving he's moving there you go
[Music]
that's the other mechanics that's fine
don't just start coming in like your
habitual Nilsa duty it was contact and
pushed on her face another mechanic
contact ate too much weight
[Music]